progressive democrats back here at home
are once again preventing the
president's social spending measures
from getting through
the democrat-run congress congressional
correspondent chad pergram live on
capitol hill with that part of the story
chad we saw what happened last night but
how much blood bad blood is there
between moderate and progressive
democrats well brett progressives are
demanding assurances from moderates
kirsten sinema and joe manchin in the
united states senate that they will vote
for the social spending bill there is
also distrust between the house and
senate that's why liberals are forcing
leaders to do the infrastructure bill
and the social spending bill in tandem
both president biden and house speaker
nancy pelosi failed to close the
deal what's your response when you hear
that sort of dissension in your caucus
about where you stand when you present a
very positive picture of where you are i
have respect for all of our members on
in the full spectrum of the big tent
that is our democratic party everybody
has
the chance to say what they wish
are mad because they believe moderates
prevailed reducing the overall cost of
the bill plus they nixed family leave
and beefed up medicare liberals are
flexing their muscles
they
are coming into their power in terms of
understanding just how
much power they willed
on the hill
and how much power they willed
throughout the democratic party
but which side has the upper hand
moderates control the policy that's
because democrats hold narrow margins in
the house and senate that dictates what
can pass but liberals control the
politics there is strength in numbers
brett
chad what's the timeline here
the best case scenario is probably two
weeks even if they had a deal today then
you're into thanksgiving they are a long
ways off from final language the other
major deadline is december 3rd that's
when lawmakers must fund the government
to avoid a shutdown and there will be
another donny brook over the debt
ceiling and they could enroll all this
into a big bill in early december the
other deadline which of course is always
a big deadline here on capitol hill is
christmas
right
all right chad we'll follow it thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else